Hey YouTubers. It's Charlie,this is going to be my Game of Thrones bonus video for the week.
Normally I do it on sunday,but there's so much Walking Dead stuff and Stephen Amell on Summerslam.
So I'm gonna be talking about Gravedigger, Cleganebowl, all about the Hound today.
Real quick reminder, new round of the giveaway starts now.It's a $20 Amazon Gift Card.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
There've been rumors that Rory McCann, the actor that plays the Hound,has been sighted in Belfast.
But he hasn't been seen on the set or anything, so we don't know if he's going to be in season 6.
But it's totally possible He will come back.
If you remember way back in season 4, His ending was kinda ambiguous.It's a situation like Stannis is in right now
Where it's like you're pretty sure they're dead, but you're not sure.
Most of the theories about what happens to him have been spun out of the books, just because there's so much more material.
So many more characters and storylines going on.But even in the books it's still not confirmed that he's coming back.
So when people talk about the Gravedigger, they talk about Cleganebowl, those are two theories that depend on each other.
And they depend on the context of the books.
But talking about the Hound coming back on the show, assuming you've never read the books before
They did seed a couple clues that the story isn't completely done with him yet.
He was mostly invoked by Arya storyline, beacuse he spent most of the season 4  with her.
So let's just start with the Gravedigger,because that theory spawns all the other theories about the Hound coming back.
This is taken from Brienne storyline in book 4 which has dramatically changed but the show could do it in season 6.
So potential spoilers for the Quiet Isle and the Gravedigger.
So remember in season 4 Brienne left King's Landing on a mission to find to find the surviving Starks
She got Oathkeeper,she got a new set of armor and she got Podrick
She does the same things in the books it just happens at a different point in time
But during her journey she comes upon a place called the Quiet Isle.
It's a little Island here at the mouth of the Trident
Which is basically populated by what you could consider monks
people who go to atone for their sins.They call them Penitants.
The people who've taken this vow of servitude
typically cover themselves up in wrapping so you can't make out their faces.
They're all relatively anonymous
While they're visiting the Quiet Isle, they meet someone called the Gravedigger.
The reason that people think this mysterious Gravedigger person is the Hound.
Is because the elder brother who's kind of in charge of that order of penitents.
Know's way too much about what the Hound has experienced, like the pain that he has experienced  in his life
For it to be a coincidence
You have to remember that this is a obscure little tiny island
It's not like super famous in Westeros.There's plenty of other centers of worship that you can go to to atone for your sins.
Brienne also noticed that the Gravedigger is bigger than her, the Hound is also bigger than her
And he is already one of the biggest people that she has ever met.
There are very few people that are bigger than her, the Hound and the Mountain
The wound that he seems like he has is in a very similar place to a wound the Hound sustained
during book 3,when he was a the inn of the crossroads with Arya Stark.
The TV show crossed that encounter with Brienne storyline
like the wound that Brienne gave to the Hound would be comparable to the one Gravedigger has in the books
Then there's this dog.
A Hound, you might say
That follows the Gravedigger around that he is very friendly with
And when the elder brother of the order is talking to Brienne about the death of the Hound he speaks in metaphors.
As if the persona of the Hound died,and the person that lived on is someone else.
So Sandor Clegane might still be alive living under a different name.
And if that wasn't enough the Hounds horse -Stranger is also seen on the Quiet Isle
So all signs point to the Hound having slinked to the Quiet Isle to just forget about his life as the Hound.
Fuck the king. Fuck the Mountain. Fuck everybody.Peace im a outta here.
Kind of situation
So even if you guy haven't read the books that sound like a lot of evidence that the Hound might still be alive
just living under assumed name.
That's where we get to Cleganebowl
Let me know, do you think that the Hound is going to comeback on the TV show?
Do you think Jaqen whacking Arya and her lying about missing the Hound.
Is a clue that he might comeback
If the show decides to bring him back
I would expect them to do it in slighty different way
Just adjusting for the storylines that they changed from the books
But there's a lot of other characters that we are hoping might comeback
Taking on different personas
Jon Snow being the biggest one
Like, they comeback but they're not the same person that died.
Jon Snow is just the extreme example.
In that he literally died.
So moving on to Cleganebowl
Now we have to talk what's going on with Cersei in King's Landing
And her trial with the Faith
It was kinda left hanging at the end of the season
She did her penance walk but she hasn't had her trial yet.She still has to have a trial.
She confessed to the High Sparrow, took the walk but that wasn't like in exchange for the trial.
Like she still has to go on trial for all the bad things that she's done
She believed confessing would bring more favorable outcome during the trial.
It really remains to be seen how long they're gonna drag this trial situation in King's Landing across season 6.
It could take the whole season
When we had Tyrion's trial during season 4 it took place over a number of episodes.
But a lot of people are hoping Cersei chooses Robert Strong aka. the Frankenmountain as her champion in a trial by combat.
Thinking he's unbeatable and she would be able to walk scot-free from whatever charge they lay on her.
There really aren't that many  people that we know about in Game of Thrones could beat the Mountain when he was whole.
Now that he is FrankenMountain he seems almost invincible.
So who might come along and has a chance to beat him?
Well the Hound is just one of those few people
So a small portion of the fandom thinking that the penitent gravedigger,who might be the *Hound*
Will come back and be faith's champion during the Ceisei trial.
Therefore you windup with Clegane vs Clegane.
That's Cleganebowl
You guys can decide how you feel about that.
Some of the theories do line up but that's only when you're looking at the context the book provides.
If he comes back on the show, there's no precedent for Cleganebowl.
The show provided no context for the *Hound* wanting to go back to king's Landing to fight his brother.
So if the show brings him back
And they want to do this crazy Cleganebowl theory, which i don't totally buy into.
They'd have to establish motivation fot the Hound going back to King's  Landing.
And right now i see no reason for him to do that.
Sure he hates his brother, but he doesn't care about the rest of the kingdom.
And his brother isn't a threat to the rest of the kingdom.
He's just Cersei's golem
So aslong as his brother, or Frankenmountain, however you want to think about him.
Doesn't come and start pushing-up on the Hound again,then there's really no reason for him to care.
So you guys can let me know, if the Hound comes back on the show.waht do you think he's going to be doing?
Will he get tied up in the Sansa plotline.This "North Remembers" storyline.
Do you think it'll have anything remotely to do with what's going on in King's Landing.
Really with everything they changed so far, I think his best shot is being tied up with what's going on with
Brienne,Sansa and The North Remembers storyline again.
We don't know how long it's gonna be before Arya is back in Westeros.
So, if they want to tie him to Arya then he would have to windup in the east.
And that would be a huge change from the books.
So there's a number of different routes they can go if they decide to bring the Hound back
Just incase you guys didn't see it.
"Fear the Walking Dead" premiered last night on AMC.It's "The Walking Dead" spinoff show
They just announced that it shattered a cable record.
It's like the most popular cable premiere in history.
I think it was like 10 Million viewers,just in the US.
Now this is for like a series premiere
Just for comparison.The ratings comparison.
In the US. Just taking the US ratings because they don't measure ratings outside the US.
"The Walking Dead" season 5 the main show
premiered with like, 70.. little over 70 million viewers.
but it had 5 seasons to build popularity.
when it first premiered it was a fraction of that.It was way less popular
Than "Fear the Walking Dead" started off with.
"Game of Thrones" season 5 started with about 8 million viewers.
The problem with that is it's HBO premium cable so fewer people get the channel.
So people that watch "Game of Thrones" are every bit as passionate and connected to the show
as the people that watch "The Walking Dead"
It's just "The Walking Dead" is way cheaper to watch so a lot more people get the channel.
If you're one of the fans, you should totally "fear the Walking Dead"
There's 6 episodes in season 1.
I'm gonna be doing videos each week for it.
I'm doing a weekly giveaway.
It's already been confirmed for a 15 episodes season 2.
that'll start next year.
so you can click here for my episode 1 video from that, that I posted last night.
And you can click here to learn all about the life of the mad king.
king Aerys II.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody let's high-five I'll see you guys tonight.